well after months of attacking each
other president trump and former vice
president biden will finally face off
tomorrow night on the very same stage
the first of the three presidential
debates is typically the highest rated
and has the highest stakes but
can it change the race at this point at
o'keefe joins us from the debate site in
cleveland ed good morning to you
what will you be watching for well tony
good morning look there's little debate
about the differences between president
trump and former vice president joe
biden and this debate
could go in all sorts of directions but
history suggests that at the end of the
night
there'll be at least one big moment that
we all remember
there you go again there you go again
there's no debate
it's such a nasty one here one line can
define a campaign
are you better off than you were four
years ago or
a candidate senator you're no jack
kennedy
in 1960 the candidates need no
introduction jfk one
if you were watching radio listeners
couldn't see
richard nixon's pale face the nervous
pats
now in our social media age moments tend
to be
more powerful mr trump i want to start
with you 60 minutes correspondent john
dickerson
has had a front row seat whole binder's
full of women
in 2012 president obama ridiculed mitt
romney for calling russia
a threat in the 1980s are now calling to
ask for their foreign policy back what
was seen as a winning debate moment for
president
obama in 2012 over the course of years
has not survived so well
but the format has held up even if
there's debate
if the events live up to their name do
you consider these to be
debates these are not really debates
really they are
joint appearances or they are interviews
held in parallel but joe biden's first
question in the 2008 vp debate came from
sarah palin hey can
[Applause]
humor helped ronald reagan stop
questions about his age
in 84. i am not going to exploit
for political purposes my opponents
youth and inexperience
and it's not just candidates in the hot
seat more astronauts have actually
traveled to outer space
than have sat in a moderator's chair for
a presidential
or vice presidential debates good
evening cbs's elaine quijano moderated
the last
vice presidential debate let me just
mention they have not
elaine let me finish a sentence you can
feel that temperature sort of rising to
release
i just had a reflexive moment where it
was basically
pulling it out of my parental toolbox
gentlemen you can't meet the nixon
standard at home cannot
understand either one of you when you
speak over each other
and remember sometimes it's not
something said
but sarah palin's wink how long have i
been at this like
five weeks donald trump's looming stare
or al gore's
size as he crept up
check out the look on george w bush's
face
or his father caught looking at his
watch which
emphasized that idea that he was out of
touch with
the cares of normal people how has a
national debt
personally affected each of your lives
bush's answer
didn't help i'm sure it has i love my
grand grandchildren i want to think that
there is a very interesting dynamic when
candidates have to answer the questions
of real people
it's harder for them to dodge in this
first debate there will be a sole
moderator asking questions and while we
expect it to
look very similar to past debates it may
sound a little different that's because
there will be fewer
audience members there because of social
distancing that might mean
less applause and less cheering and past
moderators elaine and john think
that's a good thing tony yeah i tend to
agree ed thank you very much and you can
hear
john dickerson discuss other pivotal
moments from past debates on today's cbs
this morning podcast you can listen
on your favorite podcast platform